[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this one I can't believe nobody
wanted this coffee table book Andy what
is it Conan dinosaurs in lingerie
[Applause]
the t-rex
there's look at this one right up here
it's a pterodactyl and then check out
what's going on here a triceratops
oh yeah it's a fifty Shades of Grey
Triceratops I can't believe this one
didn't sell I can't I would want this
over this gingerbread orgies
[Applause]
look at it for a while that way you
wouldn't think but that actually that
scene smells very good another clip from
the abyss what a great coffee table book
check this out book of yo mama
compliments yo mama so organized she
always knows where her keys out
[Applause]
you never hear a yo mama complement yeah
very nice positivity this is one I would
buy out like this douchebag dogs hate
that dog yeah check these guys out right
here
ah this is great I don't know why this
didn't sell I can't understand great
inventors using dumb inventions there's
Thomas Edison with Slap Chop yeah and
check this out there's Albert Einstein
right there would be flow be useful yeah
and then yeah old nickel a Tesla using a
Snuggie that's right Tesla who gave us
alternating current you certainly did
professor
this one's just weird it's called big
Newton's it's a very particular audience
yeah it's just like big humans I love
these fantastic happy dead in our if it
keeps going poisoning this is the bet
this is the best one just the commitment
this is sleep by now yeah this is my
favorite one fun with Taylor Lautner's
eyes
Lazar
people go tiny here yeah there's even
more
there's upside
[Applause]
that's just a good book
[Applause]